وصف الإسرائيليون جنوده بالجرذان،
فأباد جنودهم وأحرقهم،
وصنع من جثثهم طريقا ليمضي به إلى الأمام،
هو من وقف مع القضية الفلسطينية بحزم
ورفض التهاون في الحق الفلسطيني،
وقف أيضا مع مصر وسوريا لاستعادة أراضيهم
التي احتلها العدو الصهيوني،
نعم يا سادة إنه الرئيس الجزائري
هواري بو مدين،،،
في عام ١٩٧٣
كانت إسرائيل تحتل الضفة في قناة السويس المصرية،
ومحتلة أيضا لمدينة القنيطرة في الجولان السورية،
عندها أخذ الرئيس الجزائري هواري بومدين
الهاتف واتصل بنظارئه السوفييت
وطلب منهم صفقة طائرات عاجلة
وصفقة أسلحة متطورة،
ثم اتصل بو مدين بالرئيس المصري أنور السادات
وقال له عليك أن تضع كل إمكانيات الجزائر
تحت تصرفك وجنودنا أيضا
وكل ما تحتاجون إليه من العدة والعتاد
يكفي فقط أن تطلبوا منا ما تريدون،
فرد السادات أننا نحتاج  لمزيد من الدبابات
والسوفييت يرفضون إعطاءنا،
عندها طار بومدين إلى الإتحاد السوفييتي،
وطالب بتعجيل صفقة السلاح وفتح حسابا في البنك بالدولار
لضمان العملية،
فانتصرت مصر وسوريا بعد ذلك،
وقال السادات أن جزء كبير من الانتصار
كان بعد الله بفضل الجزائر ورئيسهم بومدين،،
بالعودة إلى المعركة
فقد شاركت الجزائر بفوجها الثامن للمشاة الميكانيكية،
على الجبهة المصرية، أما قائد الصهيونية في ذلك الحين
شارون فقد استهزء هو جنوده بالجنود الجزائريين،
وكانوا يصفونهم بالجرذان،
لكن أبطال الجزائر جعلوهم يتذوقون الموت وهم أحياء،
في أسوء مشهد لشارون وجنوده،
وصنعوا بهم هزيمة نكراء،
ليخرج بعدها قائد أركان الجيش الصهيوني بتصريحه الشهير،
(لست مسؤولا عما حدث في هذه الهزيمة لجنودنا،
التي صنعها قادة إسرائيل،
لقد اسهزأوا بالجيش الجزائري،
وكل ماحدث لنا كان بسب الاستهتار بالجزائريين)..
فقد توقع شارون وجنوده أنهم يستطيعون إنهاء الجنود الجزائريين
بأسلحتهم البدائية وسيفر جنود الجزائر بمجرد قرع طبول الحرب،
لكنهم نصبوا للمحتل الفخ وخسر الصهاينة في يوم واحد
فقط ٩٠٠ قتيل من أفضل جنودهم،
وأُعطبت ١٥٢ دبابة، وكان قائد أركان الصهاينة قد قال
( أن المصريون خدعوهم وأوهموهم بأن الميناء خالٍ من الحماية،
بينما هم كانوا قد تركوا الحماية للجنود الجزائريين،
وبالنظر للجزائريين فكانوا لا يملكون إلا أسلحة بسيطة
وغير قادرين على عرقلة جنودنا)
وبدأت المعركة وما هي إلا دقائق
حتى أمطر الجزائريون طائرات العدو بالصواريخ،
فأسقطت طائرة وأصابت اثنتين،
وقصفت مواقع العدو بالمدفعية الثقيلة،
ليصعق العدو من هول المعركة، ويطلب النجدة،
وفي الوقت ذاته فقد أعلن الرئيس الأمريكي حالة الطوارئ
داخل القيادة الأمريكية،
لأنها المرة الأولى التي تسقط فيها طائرة من طائراتهم العظيمة
وكانتC5 جلاكسي،
عندها صرخ شارون في جنوده،
عليكم أن تبيدوا هذه الفئران الجبانة وعلموهم كيف يتعاملون مع جنودنا،
لا تتركوا بيتا واحدا في الجزائر إلا وهو متوشحا الزي الأسود،
فاندفع جيش الصهاينة نحو الجنود الجزائريين
وهناك وجدوا أنفسهم محاصرين من جميع الجهات،
وما هي إلا دقائق حتى تم تدمير اللواء المدرع للصهاينة بأكمله،
وتم تحطيم جنود المظلات في وقت قصير،
فقال الأمريكان والصهاينة عندها عن الجزائريين
أنهم وحوش وسحرة فنحن لا نحارب بشرا بل شياطين
يضربوننا ويختفون، وقذائفنا لا تصل إليهم،
ورمياتهم تحرقنا، وأسرت القوات الجزائرية ٨٠ جنديا صهيونيا
برتب مختلفة، ورفضوا المساومة
لأن الصهاينة لا يملكون أي أسير جزائري، ..
انتهت المعركة بإهانة لإسرائيل لم ترها من قبل،
وعاد جيشهم يجر أذيال الخيبة
وكان ذلك فقط حين استهانوا بجنود الجزائر واستحقروهم،
وكان الجزائريون يمتلكون قائدا
ك هواري بومدين،،،
.....